¿Y qué tal el petróleo, el gas y las empresas mineras?
Bueno, tal vez es un tanto cliché hablar de ellas.
La corrupción en ese sector, no es una sorpresa.
Hay corrupción en todas partes, así que, ¿por qué centrarse en ese sector?
Bueno, porque hay mucho en juego.
En 2011, las exportaciones de recursos naturales
sobrepasaron en casi 19 veces los flujos de ayuda
en África, Asia y América Latina. 19 a 1.
Eso es un montón de escuelas, universidades,
hospitales y empresas nacientes,
muchas de los cuales nunca se materializaron y jamás lo harán
porque simplemente parte de ese dinero ha sido robado.
Ahora volvamos al petróleo y a las empresas mineras,
y vayamos a Dan Etete y el trato de mil millones.
Perdónenme, voy a leer el siguiente fragmento
porque es un tema muy vivo y nuestros abogados
han pasado en esto con cierto detalle
y quieren que lo haga bien.
Ahora, en la superficie, el trato parecía sencillo.
Filiales de Shell y Eni
pagaron al gobierno Nigeriano por el bloque.
El gobierno Nigeriano transfirió
precisamente la misma cantidad, cada dólar,
a una cuenta destinada de una empresa fantasma
cuyo propietario oculto era Etete.
No está mal para un lavador de dinero condenado.
Y aquí está la cosa.
Después de muchos meses de explorar
y la lectura de cientos de páginas del expediente,
se encontraron pruebas de que, de hecho,
Shell y Eni habían sabido que los fondos
se transferirían a la empresa fantasma,
y francamente, es difícil creer que no sabían
con quién realmente estaban lidiando allí.
Ahora, no solo se debe hacer este tipo de esfuerzos
para averiguar a dónde fue el dinero en negocios como éste.
Es decir, son recursos del Estado.
Se supone que se utilizarán para el beneficio
del pueblo en su país.
Pero en algunos países, los ciudadanos y periodistas
que están intentando exponer historias como esta
han sido hostigados y detenidos
y algunos incluso han arriesgado sus vidas por hacerlo.
Por último, hay quienes creen
que la corrupción es inevitable.
Que es así como se hacen los negocios.
Que es demasiado complejo y difícil de cambiar.
En efecto, ¿qué? Solo lo aceptamos.
Pero como activista e investigadora,
tengo una visión diferente,
porque he visto lo que puede suceder
cuando una idea cobra impulso.
En el petróleo y el sector minero, por ejemplo,
ahora hay el comienzo
de un estándar de transparencia mundial real
que podría abordar algunos de estos problemas.
En 1999, cuando Global Witness llamó
a las compañías petroleras a hacer acuerdos transparentes,
algunas personas se rieron de la gran ingenuidad
de esa simple idea.
Pero literalmente cientos de grupos de la sociedad civil
de todo el mundo, se unieron
para luchar por la transparencia,
y ya se está convirtiendo en la norma y la ley.
Dos terceras partes del valor
del petróleo y las compañías mineras del mundo
se encuentran ahora cubiertas por leyes de transparencia. Dos terceras partes.
Este cambio esta ocurriendo.
Esto es progreso.
Pero no hemos terminado; falta mucho.
Porque realmente no se trata de la corrupción
en algún lugar por ahí, ¿verdad?
En un mundo globalizado, la corrupción
es un negocio que está en todas partes
y que necesita soluciones mundiales,
apoyadas y empujadas por todos nosotros, como ciudadanos del mundo,
aquí mismo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)